hey las vegas
lvmpd motor school here we're out here
live at the las vegas motor speedway
this is uh week one motor school end a
week challenge we have 19 students
we've got students from lvmpd students
from henderson north town nhp kingman
bullhead city
and we're about to begin our slow race
for our end of week challenge
so the goal of the race is to make it
last
to the end line without putting your
foot down without dropping your bike
without going out of the pattern
if you win
you need to go back in line at the end
if you lose you're out
line up and heckle away
oh henderson henderson wins that one
i try sarge nice try
you win henderson back in line
that's good
all right we got a trooper versus lvmpd
sergeant this lvmpd sergeant was here as
a motor officer he promoted and now he's
tested to come back to the bureau
oh foot down
nhp wins that one
[Music]
sarge what happened
you gotta represent for bullhead
so we have uh nhp i'm sorry henderson
officer officer everhurt
and officer rubio for lvmpd that one
didn't last long
henderson wins
all right two lvmpd officers officer
hazel stop and officer murphy
oh no
no
nice try rob
all right we got a kingman officer and a
henderson sergeant
[Music]
another quick raise good job hi burger
three
so what's the tips and tricks to win in
the slow race you think
a lot of what we call tcb
a lot of throttle clutch and brake
keep your vision up look where you want
to go
and obviously take the longest path to
the finish line
that was good elmer that was good
wow
ready
for sure
[Music]
north town's here on their bmws not very
good balance though
yeah bmw is built for speed
definitely not
balanced
[Music]
[Music]
ready three two
oh i mean the bike is 850 pounds
as it starts to go down it's definitely
hard to keep up
but that's what team works for
there has to be one there has to be one
hey i like this we're gonna let the
yellow shirts take each other out
oh rich you're such a sad individual
this is supposed to be a fun time week
one motor school they're just learning
how to maneuver these bikes and you got
to come in with negativity not nice
[Applause]
[Music]
what are you doing
get back in line moses
get back where you were at
even up the line
up the line
for a while now
ready
ready three two one
[Music]
breathe
[Music]
oh
[Music]
get over a line
ready
ready
three two one go
[Music]
hey steph
can you see ken over there yelling
[Applause]
[Music]
come
[Music]
see you screwed on up the two yellow
shirts could have taken each other out
all right we're down to our final four
three two one
foot has to come up all right three two
one go
up there now work better
[Music]
oh
[Music]
kingman henderson and metro left that's
a great
great turnout for us hey come on
highburgers slow as fast
[Music]
here we go here we go here we go
come on
put down
here we are for the finals
final round
[Music]
anderson has to pick it up
ready
here we go three
two
one go
all you have to do is keep it
up the final race for the slow race
henderson versus lvmpd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
there he goes officer rebar for the win
all right
all right guys we got to clean up the
track we're going to head back to the
station have a good night